hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over the museo gamut which if
you're not too familiar with is a very
sharp variation within the King's gambit
now the Kings game it starts out with
pawn to e4 pawn e5 pawn to f4 any time
you're going to be gambling material you
typically want to have some sort of
compensation that could be a leading
spatial advantage it could be a
developmental advantage but you
definitely want to have some sort of
compensation
so the musio gambit is the accepted line
in the King's game it's a pawn takes on
f4 and then the Knights going to come to
f3 simple development move but also
getting ready to castle on the Kings
side so that this rook can be on the
semi-open F file now from here Blackson
come down to g5 typically in the King's
gambit you will see the pawn come to h4
so that when the pawn pushes forward the
knight has a nice little outpost here on
g5 after the bishop comes to c4 there's
going to be a lot of attacking on this
pawn on f7 which is the weakest Square
for black early on a lot of people
always ask why is this f7 Square so weak
it's because the King is the only piece
that is actually defending this so when
it is attacked or double attacked the
King is the only one that's protecting
it so obviously things can change later
on but early on into the game it's going
to be very very weak for black so
instead the musio gambit of bringing the
pawn up to h4 and creating this outpost
for the night why does instead gonna
bring their Bishop over to c4 really
putting a lot of pressure on this f7
Square early on and also getting the
pieces developed as quickly as possible
now the goal from black with this pawn
to g5 because it is weakening the king
side and you won't see it all the time
but the goal behind this is to continue
to push forward so blacks going to play
pawn to g4 but instead of actually
moving the night the knight can no
longer come to g5 because he doesn't
have his out posted pawn on h4 instead
White's going to castle on the King side
again really ramping up that development
and after the pawn takes here on f3 then
the Queen's going to come
to f3 and this is the musio game it so
do just want to let you know if you play
the Kings gambit you will not see this
every time your opponent may instead of
bringing his pawn to f5
excuse me g5 early on he may develop one
of his knights he could always play a
move like d6 he could get his dark
square Bishop involved into the game
early on so you may not see this all the
time but if you are a Abid player of the
King's gambit you definitely will have
many many opportunities to play this and
what I've seen in my own games is
anytime you play the musio gambit your
opponent atypically is going to be very
confused they also may think you're
crazy because you're just sacrificing
material you're sacrificing pawns and
knights and possibly bishops later on
and they're just so confused but there's
so many different traps that black can
fall into it's going to be very very
hard for them to actually play a very
precise game what's also great about it
is even though white gives up so much
material early on if you were to run
this analysis through computers in many
different variations we're going to be
going over why it's not too far behind
sometimes even leading as far as you
know the computer is concerned because
he has such a strong attack on the black
King so just keep that in mind we're
going to be going over about four
different variations in the musio gambit
even if you're not a very very
aggressive player this is definitely
going to be good for you to watch just
to see how pieces interact together and
how if you have your opponent's Kings on
the ropes it can be very very good
doesn't matter which opening it is but
this specifically the musio gambit is
for very aggressive players and also
those players going to be adapting the
King's gambit opening now the first
thing we can see is that White has a
huge lead in development he's already
castled on the King side he has both his
major pieces the Queen here on f3 and
the rook here on f1 both attacking the
semi open file he already has his
light-square attacking this f7 square
black has none of his eighth ring pieces
developed so a couple things you want to
keep
mind when playing the musio game but you
want to be attacking the entire game if
there's any time where you're kind of
bringing your pieces back or you're
playing somewhat passive you're not
attacking the opponent's king you're
probably playing the musio game bit
wrong so sometimes you have to give up
material but you definitely want to make
sure that your opponent's king is
running around he's not castled if he
castles in the musio gambit you are
playing this gambit wrong so just keep
those in mind while we look at this now
the immediate threat that White has is
bringing his Queen to f4 then that only
does he have his queen and rook
attacking this square on f7 buddy also
has as we said the bishop there on c4 so
because of this the first move you may
see the four variations will be going
over you may see Queen to f6 now from
here what has the option to be even more
aggressive and I always tell people if
you're going to play it an aggressive
opening you need to be very aggressive
so from here white can play pawn to e5
this is an important move for multiple
reasons one after the Queen takes here
on e5 this does two things the first
thing it does is it allows white to
sacrifice more material but also it
opens up this efile white really wants
to have both this efile and a semi-open
F file to attack this King again the
entire point of this opening is to
attack the black King with everything
that white has from here White's going
to sacrifice even more material he's
going to bring his bishop to f7 attack
this King here on ei now black does not
have to take this material he can always
bring his Queen or excuse me his King to
d8 now if we look at it from here White
has a huge lead in development as you
can see the black King and the rest of
the pieces on the eighth-ranked are not
going anywhere so it's going to be very
very easy for white to not only equalize
but have a huge attack on the black King
and the black King can't really go
anywhere safely for a long time more
times than not you're going to go ahead
and see the black King take here on f7
which i think is a little bit easier
for white to play because you're pretty
much going to be fighting an open King
in the middle of the board for the rest
of the game from here white can play
pawn to d4
since we're sacrificing knights and
bishops you might as well sacrifice one
more pawn after the Queen takes here on
d4 then the bishop can come to e3 nice
little move gaining tempo meaning that
you're going to develop your pieces and
force your opponent to move his pieces
back the Queen cannot take here on e3
because you're just going to lose that
Queen the pawn can't take here on e3
because the rook here spinning down the
pawn to the king obviously the pawn
can't take here because the Queen is
it's being pinned down to the King by
this Queen here so blacks going to have
to move his Queen back now if we look at
this you can start to see White has a
ton of material all starting to you know
gear up and attack and black has moved
to pieces he's moved his King and he's
also moved his Queen here which right
now is just being chased all over the
board now black has a few options here
you can tell if the Queen moves away
then white can either take with his
Bishop here he can also take with his
Queen here but I do want to go over one
of the traps that you may see because a
lot of times when you do play the musio
game but your opponent's just going to
be looking up to gobble as much material
as possible so one of the mistakes that
you may see black make is Queen taking
here on b2 now this is a mistake for
multiple reasons but one the Queen is no
longer really in the mix of the game
this is a problem because White has such
a huge attack the blacks just not going
to be able to defend it the Queen can
now take here on f4 now how is he going
to defend you can see that the square
here on f6 really needs to be defended
if he tries to bring his Queen back
let's say Queen to f6 then the Queen can
now come over to c4 check and then the
black Queen is going to fall doesn't
really matter where black moves the next
move if white wanted to he could come
take this Queen check and then that
would have to be you know answered so
definitely going to be a huge mistake
for black obviously he has the
opportunity instead of bringing his
queen back he could bring his knight to
f6 this is also going to be a mistake
white can now play Knight to c3 again
giving all of his pieces involved into
the game even though he's down the
material it does not matter if your
opponent has more pieces if you have
more pieces in the fight especially if
your opponent's king is in the mill the
board like it is right now it would be a
mistake for black to take this but again
it is very tempting if he does take this
knight on c3 then the bishop can come to
d4 in the Queen's going to fall he can't
take with his Queen right here but black
has to find some way to stop this attack
with Queen takes on f6 the knight can't
move if the King moves doesn't really
matter then the Queen can fall or white
also has the option to come and take
with his Queen here on f6 so the Queen
is going to fall and black is going to
not only be down the material but as we
can say over and over again the King is
still in the middle the board so
definitely going to be a mistake for the
Queen to come down to b2
but even if he doesn't whites still
going to be able to capture that pawn
back on f4 and have a lot of fighting
opportunity now so far we've pretty much
assumed that black is taking all the
material I do want to kind of go over
you know another option that you may see
just so you have an eye for okay well
black did not take all material so what
happens then so just something to think
about if instead if he does not take
this pawn on d4 you could always bring
his Queen back to let's say f5 from here
the bishop can just take here on f4 and
then it really depends on where black
goes let's say he tries Bishop to g7 or
he could always try Knight to c6 with
both of these moves doesn't really
matter the Queen can always swing over
to b3 he has all these attacks on the
King because again as we talked about
the king is in the center of the board
now we also do have the discovered
attack anytime this bishop
moves depending on where the Queen moves
there's going to be a discovered attack
with this rook on the King also
attacking this Queen here on f5 so black
really really is going to have to pay a
lot of attention and think very closely
where he's moving because there's so
many different traps that he can fall
into so definitely want to keep that in
mind those are some of the variations
again that you'll see if the Queen early
on into the game comes to that f6
squares we talked about now another
variation you may see come up is the
in-between move which black sometimes
one employ and that is black Bishop to
c5 attacking this King here the King is
going to have to move SWE's is going to
come over to h1 and then now you may see
the Queen come to f6 so kind of along
that the same lines but from here it's
going to be a little bit different
instead white can now play Knight to c3
again starting to develop his pieces
white is no longer sacrificing his
bishop on f7 so he's no longer down as
much material but he still has a huge
huge attacking advantage it's still
going to be very very hard for black to
castle obviously again that is a theme
you definitely never want your opponent
to castle if they're black in the musio
game it so doesn't really matter where
your opponent goes let's say he now
tries to bring his knight involved into
the game let's say to c6 again more than
likely your opponent would like to
castle onto the Queen side then you can
now play it say Knight to d5 very very
strong move that only attacking this
Queen here on f6 because it's kind of
out in the open
also attacking this pawn here on f4
putting a lot of pressure on c7 forking
both the rook here and the King here on
EI really going to be forcing this Queen
to make another move maybe something to
desus as we can tell from the board if
he doesn't move something like Queen to
d6
he'll be falling into a trap so he has
to be very very careful the next move
you can always play you know pawn to c3
you can then push forward with pawn to
d4 you're going to have a huge spatial
and developmental advantage and you're
going to be putting a lot of pressure
still on black so doesn't really matter
even if you see this in-between move
you're probably not going to be
sacrificing the bishop early on to the
game but you're still going to have a
very very strong attack now a lot of
people that are just not familiar with
the opening at all may try to develop
one of their Knights seems logical
typically you always hear nights before
bishops as far as development so you may
see Knight to c6 as a common move from
here very easy since you no longer have
to move your King and there's nothing
protecting this pawn here on f4 White's
just going to go ahead and gobble up
that material now from here since
there's all these pieces just looking
down on this f7 square black has to
defend that in some way really the best
move for him is a move like Queen to f6
but from here this is going to be a
mistake from black after the Queen takes
and the knight takes the rook can just
take here on f6 and then White's going
to have a very very good game so just
keep that in mind again the black King
is still in a lot of trouble here again
the bishop is now attacking this square
on f7 so definitely going to be a very
very good game from white now black also
does have the option instead of bringing
his seed knight to c6 here he can always
have the option of bringing his other
knight to f6 now from here white has a
few options but typically again you're
just going to be bringing this Queen to
f4 putting a lot of pressure on the King
side again this night here on f6 isn't
doing a whole lot of good now if you
wanted to the pawn can always come to d5
again trying to counter the center of
the board obviously trying to put some
pressure on there but the pawn can just
recapture on d5 again the knight can't
really come here to d5 that's going to
be gg because the Queen can just come
here to f7 also that the Queen can't
really come here because he's just going
to lose that to the bishop so he can try
some counter play but anytime you see
your opponent move one of their knights
it's going to be extremely extremely
hard for them to have a good game
because they're really just not
protecting what need
to be protected and early on into the
game what needs to be protected is you
need to be protecting this f7 square and
the Knights aren't doing a whole lot of
good because you can just come in gobble
up this f4 square and there's just so
much attacking prowess that you have
with your Queen rook and Bishop it's
going to be very very hard for black so
as you can see definitely a lot of
attacking options any time I'm looking
at the board and I see that I have a
bishop Queen rook King Castle and I look
at my opponent and I see that he has no
pieces moved this is an opening that
excites me so again if you're an
aggressive player if you haven't tried
this out already I definitely recommend
it I would love for you to send me some
of your games I love to give you some
pointers if you have some questions or
maybe you came up with a new variation
that you've been playing with in the
musio gamete and it's going really well
for you I just enjoy attacking lines
like the musio game so hopefully you
guys enjoy the video if you haven't seen
this already you know definitely excited
that you got to see this leave comments
let me know what you guys think and I
will see you guys in the next video
thanks for watching